C'est la nouvelle vitrine de la Russie.
Longtemps une des villes
les plus secrètes du monde.
C'est la plus grande base navale
russe de L'extrême Orient, Vladivostok.
Nous sommes dans une des académies
militaires les plus exigeantes du pays,
le collège Nakhimov.
Au nord de la ville, ses 560 élèves
sont réunis pour célébrer l'intégration
officielle d'un nouveau camarade.
Que la cérémonie de remise de médailles
du collège Nakhimov commence.
Rompez !
Recrue Pelebushka approchez-vous !
À vos ordres !
L'élève Ivan Pelebushka,
n'est dans l'école
que depuis quelques semaines.
Il a déjà les automatismes
d'un militaire de carrière.
Recrue Pelebushka à vos ordres.
On rentre dans cette
école dès l'âge de onze ans.
Moi Ivan Pelebushka
devient aujourd'hui officiellement
un élève
de l'école Nakhimov.
Ces jeunes gens sont destinés à former
l'élite de la flotte de guerre russe.
Voici ton insigne,
porte le avec fierté
et surtout prend en soin.
Tu fais désormais partie de notre
école, tu es l'un des nôtres.
Rompez !
Je Suis au service de la Russie.
La cérémonie s'est déroulée
sous les yeux de sa maman.
Il sera le premier marin de ma famille.
J'espère que c'est
le premier d'une longue lignée.
Ce seront ces jeunes gens
qui auront plus tard la charge de protéger
cette perle de l'extrême Orient.
la plus grande ville russe en Asie,
sur les bords de l'océan Pacifique.
L'hiver, il y fait -25 degrés.
La vie se déplace sur la mer gelée.
J'adore pêcher sur la glace,
c'est de l'adrénaline pure.
Les habitants adorent se confronter
avec les éléments et la nature hostile.
Certains nous prennent
pour des fous, mais on adore surfer.
L'été, la ville se transforme
en un petit Saint-Tropez
à la mode russe
le jour mais aussi la nuit.
Bastion imprenable de la marine
russe pendant un siècle et demi,
c'est aujourd'hui une cité
en plein boom économique capitaliste.
Avec ses collines
et ses maisons colorées,
elle a de faux
airs de San Francisco.
Dans ce nouveau Far West russe,
nous verrons qu'on
peut faire fortune en quelques années.
Nous irons dans un des plus grands
casinos d'Extrême-Orient.
Clients privilégiés, les chinois.
Pour les Chinois,
ce chiffre symbolise la richesse.
L'hiver, quand les
températures chutent,
cet eldorado peut aussi
se transformer en enfer.
La ville ne fait pas de cadeau
à ces laissés pour compte.
Quand il fait vraiment trop froid,
j'allume un petit feu.
J'arrive à me réchauffer.
Enquête dans la nouvelle
Russie du bout du monde.
Située à 8 h de vol de Moscou,
Vladivostok est au carrefour
de l'Extrême-Orient russe,
tout près de la Chine,
du Japon et de la Corée du Nord.
Le port s'est construit dans
les années 1850 autour d'un bras de mer.
L'architecture tsariste du XIXᵉ siècle
est encore très présente
dans le centre-ville.
Vladivostok a été interdite aux étrangers
et seulement accessible aux citoyens munis
d'un permis spécial jusqu'en 1990.
Des centaines de barres HLM
témoignent de ce passé communiste.
Aujourd'hui, la cité
attire des immigrants
venus de toute l'ancienne
Union soviétique.
La situation stratégique de la ville
en a fait une forteresse
imprenable pendant 150 ans.
Le port militaire abrite 50 navires
de surface et 23 sous-marins.
Derrière ces grilles,
le dernier né de la marine russe,
une corvette ultramoderne.
La Sauver Chanee,
la Parfaite en français.
Exceptionnellement, nous avons
été autorisés à monter à bord.
Capitaine rien à signaler
ce matin sur la corvette.
Le commandant Dimitri Blinov a 33 ans.
Il est né à Vladivostok, cela fait quinze
ans qu'il sert dans la marine russe.
La Parfaite a coûté
près de 130 millions d'euros.
C'est un bateau
qui échappe aux radars.
Il peut naviguer jusqu'à 28
nœuds, 48 kilomètres heure.
Son armement est dernier cri.
Ce canon a la capacité de tirer
extrêmement rapidement.
Il est très puissant,
bien plus puissant que
deux ou trois canons ordinaires.
Ce bateau, c'est le premier
d'une nouvelle génération
de vaisseaux de guerre
pour la marine russe.
Sur ces images
que nous a fourni la Marine,
on voit le canon en pleine action.
L'autre point fort du bâtiment,
c'est son système de lancement
de missiles anti sous-marin.
Il peut en lancer 45.
Chacun d'entre eux coûte 500 000 €.
Pour commander ce navire et ses
105 hommes d'équipage,
Le capitaine de corvette Blinov
a été sélectionné parmi
les meilleurs éléments de la marine russe.
Vous avez bien compris
les objectifs du jour ?
Parfait, rompez !
Sa grande fierté,
c'est d'avoir reçu à bord
la visite du président
Vladimir Poutine en personne.
C'est notre livre d'or.
Regardez ce qu'il y a d'écrit
à la première page.
Ce sont les meilleurs vœux
du président Poutine lui-même.
C'est un immense honneur
et je peux vous dire
que c'est le seul bateau de toute
la marine russe qui a sa signature.
Signe de l'importance que le président
Poutine accorde à Vladivostok,
il est venu lui-même inaugurer
le navire en septembre dernier.
Il veut restaurer
la puissance militaire russe.
Ce navire en est le symbole.
C'est au commandant Blinov
qu'est revenu l'honneur de l'accueillir.
Le président russe visitera
la corvette de fond en comble.
L'événement n'est pas anodin,
la Russie veut montrer ses muscles.
La Russie partage
19 kilomètres de frontière
avec la Corée du Nord,
un pays en conflit
avec la plupart de ses voisins.
La ville est à portée de missiles
de l'imprévisible dictateur nord-coréen.
Le fait d'être à Vladivostok,
juste à côté de la Corée du Nord,
c'est un stress supplémentaire,
est-ce que la marine
ici elle est en alerte ?
Parce qu'on sait
ce qui se passe en Corée du Nord.
Nous n'avons pas peur, pas du tout.
Tous les voisins sont
potentiellement dangereux par définition.
Mais nous sommes
des militaires professionnels
et notre pays la Russie
est en paix avec tout le monde.
Donc, aucun stress,
nous n'avons pas peur.
Mais s'ils commencent à
nous poser des problèmes,
nous sommes prêts
à répondre à toute éventualité.
Pour le marin,
commander ce joyau de la marine russe,
c'est l'aboutissement d'un rêve de gosse.
J'ai voulu devenir marin
depuis ma plus tendre enfance.
Je regardais beaucoup
de films patriotiques
et un jour, j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir visiter
un navire de guerre comme celui-ci.
Il est toujours dans le port, à côté.
Ça m'a bouleversé.
J'ai décidé de devenir un marin militaire.
C'est à quelques kilomètres de là,
qu'a été formé l'officier,
dans le collège militaire naval Nakhimov.
L'établissement a beaucoup de succès
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir
du président Poutine.
Les élèves ont tous
été choisis sur concours.
Mettez-vous en rang
et vous avancez,
colonne par colonne.
Avancez les uns
après les autres.
Les élèves ont 8 h de cours
par jour, six jours sur sept.
Le proviseur c'est un contre-amiral,
un des plus hauts gradés
de la marine russe,
le contre-amiral Bourakoff.
Veuillez-vous lever, au rapport.
Camarade, contre-amiral,
je suis le camarade
professeur principal de la classe 6B.
Le cours d'aujourd'hui
traite de l'histoire de Vladivostok.
Il sera suivi d'un exercice de poésie.
Bonjour les élèves de la classe.
Rompez !
Programme du jour, les élèves doivent
écrire un poème à la gloire de la ville.
Je vous laisse trois minutes pour écrire
votre poème en cinq strophes
sur le thème " Vladivostok,
ville de la gloire militaire ".
Voilà, mettez-vous
par groupe de quatre.
Le premier de la classe,
c'est Denis.
Il est né à Vladivostok,
il a tout juste onze ans.
Dépêche-toi, Denis ! C'est fini.
Vladivostok est une ville glorieuse.
Elle est fière et prospère, elle
nous protège. Merci les garçons.
Chacun y va de son couplet.
Vladivostok est une ville
magnifique, on est fiers de la servir.
Ville de gloire militaire, Vladivostok.
Bravo !
Vous avez tous réussi à montrer
que Vladivostok est une ville
de gloire militaire.
Il y a même des chansons
à la gloire de la ville.
Les élèves les connaissent par cœur.
Les apprentis marins
sont tous pensionnaires.
Voilà le dortoir de Denis.
Ils sont deux par chambre.
Les jeunes élèves ont
très peu de temps libre.
Chaque moment
est consacré à réviser.
Dans cet exercice,
tu dois trouver des mots
qui ont la même racine.
Par exemple, ici essaye
avec le mot initiative.
Comme chez les adultes,
les enfants ont chacun un grade.
Et le plus haut gradé ici,
c'est Dennis.
Il est chef de chambrée
en charge de trois camarades.
Je dois vérifier
s'ils font bien leurs lits,
qu'il n'y a aucun pli
sur les couvertures,
qu'ils n'oublient pas leurs livres,
que les devoirs soient faits.
Pour devenir chef, j'ai dû cultiver
responsabilité et discipline.
Mais avant tout, je dois
obéir aux ordres de mes supérieurs.
L'intérieur est spartiate.
Seule une toute petite
touche personnelle est permise.
Ça, c'est une des rares
choses qui est à moi.
C'est une maquette de bateau
qui appartenait à mon grand-père.
Qu'est-ce que
tu veux faire comme métier ?
Je veux devenir sous marinier,
faire une longue
carrière pour la marine de mon pays.
Et pourquoi ?
C'est mon rêve
depuis que je suis tout petit
Bien sûr, dans ce collège,
on apprend toutes les matières classiques.
Les mathématiques, la géographie,
la physique ou l'électronique.
Envoyez les trois torpilles !
C'est bon Le croiseur est détruit.
Il y a un cours ici
qui n'existe nulle part ailleurs.
Le cours de bataille navale.
Changez de position !
Vous devez disparaître
des radars ennemis.
Si vous ne vous faites pas tirer dessus,
c'est que vous êtes bien caché.
Un logiciel de simulation
où les élèves sont plongés dans
des situations de guerre très réalistes.
Ils jouent par équipes
les uns contre les autres.
Nous venons de faire un entraînement
et l'équipe des six cuirassés
a vaincu une équipe de trois destroyers.
Dans notre école,
on étudie tout
ce qui concerne la marine.
Cela permet aux écoliers d'apprendre
l'histoire de la construction navale.
et l'histoire de l'armement
des puissances mondiales.
C'est bientôt l'heure
de partir en week-end.
Il est temps de se changer.
Dennis et ses camarades
ont un uniforme pour chaque occasion.
Ça, c'est l'uniforme d'apparat
qu'on utilise pour les parades.
Toutes les semaines,
notre professeur principal
vient faire l'inspection des chambres,
mais surtout des uniformes.
Si tout n'est pas correctement
rangé et l'uniforme impeccable,
nous avons des avertissements.
Tous les samedis à 18h,
c'est l'heure des mamans.
Impatientes, elles viennent
toutes chercher leur fils.
Dans quelques années,
Denis réalisera peut-être
son rêve de naviguer
à bord d'un sous-marin.
Je suis tellement fière de lui.
Car c'est extrêmement difficile
de rentrer dans cette école.
Il a réussi tous les tests.
C'est tellement romantique
de vouloir devenir marin.
Mais depuis peu, Vladivostok n'est plus
seulement une forteresse militaire.
C'est une métropole
en plein boom économique.
Les cargos en transit
accostent toute l'année.
Ils transportent le bois,
le pétrole et le gaz de Sibérie.
Chaque année, en septembre,
le président Poutine accueille Japonais,
Coréens ou Chinois pour un grand
forum économique de l'Asie.
Afin d'attirer les
investissements étrangers,
il a donné à la ville
le statut de port franc.
Des milliards de roubles ont été
investis dans des travaux pharaoniques.
Deux ponts gigantesques ont été inaugurés
en 2012 pour désenclaver la ville.
Dans cet eldorado, des fortunes
se font en quelques années.
Nous avons rendez-vous avec deux
des hommes les plus riches de la ville.
Deux frères,
les frères Babokokian.
Comme beaucoup d'habitants ici,
leur famille est originaire
de l'autre bout de la Russie.
Leur père, Georges, était arménien.
Je vais vous montrer
une photo de notre vieux père.
Voilà, c'est lui au milieu.
Il était médecin
en Arménie lorsque le pays
faisait encore partie de l'U.R.S.S.
Il est venu ici
dans les années 70.
Edouard, 42 ans,
gère l'entreprise familiale au quotidien.
Son frère Armen, 45 ans,
s'occupe des relations avec les autorités,
la police, les hommes politiques.
En Russie, quand on veut faire
du business, c'est indispensable.
Mais c'est qui est le boss ?
Le boss, c'est lui.
Non, c'est vrai.
Je suis le plus petit,
mais le big boss.
Je m'occupe de faire
tourner nos cliniques au jour le jour.
Mon frère, lui, s'occupe
de la communication entre guillemets,
de tout ce qui n'est pas officiel,
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire.
Les deux hommes dirigent un petit
empire de clinique
dentaire et chirurgical en duo.
En Russie il y a dix ou quinze ans,
si tu voulais faire du business,
il fallait avoir une belle voiture.
Un bon look,
de belles chaussures,
des costumes chics chics
et une montre très chère.
Mais aujourd'hui,
ça n'a plus d'importance.
Tu peux porter ce que tu veux.
Pourtant, je vois que vous avez de très
jolies montres à vos poignets.
Oui, c'est une Roger Dubuis.
Mais non, c'est une babiole.
C'est quand même
des babioles à 100 000 $.
Celle de mon frère vaut 130 000
et la mienne est à quatre 80 000 $.
Comme chez tous les nouveaux
riches à Vladivostok,
le garage des deux frères
est bien rempli.
Berline allemande pour toute la famille.
Ça, c'est la voiture d'Armen.
Là, il y a ma voiture,
là-bas, celle de la femme d'Armen.
Et puis ça, c'est la voiture
pour les enfants.
Aucun des deux frères n'est diplômé,
mais à la mort de leur père, ils ont créé
un groupe de santé dentaire privé,
le George Dental Group,
du prénom du patriarche.
Bonjour les filles.
Ne soyez pas
intimidés par les caméras.
Aujourd'hui, ils sont à la tête
d'un petit empire de cliniques.
Ils en possèdent une dizaine
dans la région de Vladivostok.
Prix moyen d'une couronne
chez les deux frères, 1 500 €.
C'est beaucoup d'argent en Russie.
Armen et son frère se considèrent
comme les chefs de la communauté
arménienne de la ville,
environ 8000 personnes.
Alors, pour tenir leur rang,
ils ont lancé un projet très ambitieux.
On va vous faire
visiter notre église arménienne.
Avec des amis, on a commencé
les travaux en 2001.
Ça fait presque seize ans maintenant.
Ils ont entrepris de rénover
la seule église arménienne
de la ville qui était en ruine.
À leurs côtés,
la communauté a investi
plus d'un million
d'euros dans le chantier.
Ils ont fait venir ces briques
rouges directement d'Arménie.
Les deux frères y ont même été recruté
un pope pour diriger les offices.
Quand les travaux seront finis,
ça sera vraiment magnifique.
Notre grand projet, c'est de permettre
aux jeunes arméniens de Vladivostok
de se sentir arménien en venant ici.
Ils comprennent notre culture,
la musique, la langue par exemple.
N'oubliez pas qu'on est à 10 000
kilomètres de notre patrie, l'Arménie.
On essaie de reconstituer
une petite Arménie à Vladivostok.
Pour boucler leur projet,
les deux frères tentent de convaincre
un promoteur immobilier arménien, Arthur,
de remettre de l'argent
dans le chantier.
Mais l'homme se fait prier.
Moi, j'ai déjà mis 100 000 €
et là, vous me demandez
de remettre 80 000 en plus.
Ce n'est pas possible.
Il faut demander à ta banque.
Mais non, ça ne se passe pas comme ça,
je leur dois déjà beaucoup d'argent.
Ça m'énerve, ces travaux devraient
être terminés depuis plusieurs mois.
Je pense qu'il nous reste encore
un an de travail pour que tout soit fini.
Il y a beaucoup de choses à faire.
Plein de petites choses.
On dirait que
c'est presque fini.
Tu vois le français,
pense que c'est terminé.
Non, des petits détails à régler encore.
L'affaire ne se réglera pas tout de suite.
Edouard doit retourner à son
bureau, il a des rendez-vous.
Armen, le grand frère,
lui, part déjeuner.
Il possède un bateau qui
lui permet de se rendre
dans les plus beaux coins de
la ville, au bord de la mer.
Son hors-bord est amarré
dans un yacht club privé.
Ici, il y a des bateaux à trois
ou quatre millions de dollars.
Regardez comment
nous vivons ici en Russie.
Ça, c'est le yacht d'un ami
qu'il a acheté aux Etats-Unis 450 000 $.
Il s'appelle le Mamba.
C'est un ami,
c'est lui qui possède le yacht club.
Il s'appelle Roxelane,
il est en Italie en ce moment.
Avec son copain
promoteur immobilier,
il a décidé d'aller déjeuner
sur une île à seulement quelques minutes
de hors-bord de la ville.
Le pope de l'église
arménienne est de la partie.
Pour piloter son bateau,
Armen emploie un capitaine à l'année.
L'équipe débarque sur une petite plage.
Avec toutes ces bouteilles,
ils vont croire qu'on est alcooliques.
C'est un petit vin italien.
L'endroit est un des plus jolis coins
de Vladivostok, tout près du centre-ville.
L'été, cette plage privée
attire tous les VIP de la région.
Sur cette plage, il y a un petit
restaurant de fruits de mer.
Le propriétaire est un ami.
On va boire du vin
et manger du crabe tout frais.
ainsi que des coquilles Saint-Jacques,
elles viennent d'être pêchées.
Bon, elle est où la bouffe,
là je commence à avoir faim.
Ici en Russie, on commence toujours
par boire un coup avant de manger.
Santé, santé, santé.
Le prix au kilo de ce crabe du
Kamtchatka, c'est seulement 7 € le kilo.
En Europe, c'est au moins
100 euros le kilo.
C'est délicieux.
Ce serait impossible
pour moi de vivre à Moscou.
Il n'y a pas la mer.
Moi j'aime la nature, j'aime nager,
j'ai besoin de faire de l'exercice.
À Moscou, tu peux facilement
rester bloqué dans les
embouteillages pendant deux jours.
Un peu comme sur la Côte d'Azur,
un musicien vient pousser
la chansonnette à la fin du repas.
Il s'appelle Vitali.
Il a un côté chanteur de charme
des années 80 et on l'appelle l'Américain.
En fait, le guitariste
est le propriétaire de la plage
et il aime bien
venir saluer les clients.
J'aime bien
quand il y a des touristes.
Vous savez, des gens du monde
entier viennent ici.
Un peu comme à Saint-Tropez,
il affiche dans sa paillote des photos
de ses clients les plus connus.
Vitali a récupéré cette plage
à la chute de l'empire
soviétique au début des années 90.
La propriété où il réside est situé
un peu au-dessus, dans la colline.
Il y vit avec ses vieux parents.
Des survivants de l'U.R.S.S historique.
Voici mon père, il a 95 ans
et ma mère 91.
Le père est arrivé dans la région comme
aviateur à l'époque de la guerre froide.
On le voit ici en photo
avec le gouverneur de la province.
Il était pilote de chasse.
Allez, papa, raconte-nous
ce que tu faisais avant.
Avec ma patrouille de chasse,
j'ai protégé toute la région.
Pendant six ans
j'ai chassé les pilotes américains.
C'était pendant la guerre de Corée.
Je tirais sur les Américains
avec mon avion.
Pendant six ans, je leur ai tiré
dessus pour défendre la région.
Mais ce jour-là, Vitali,
le chanteur de charme,
n'a pas invité Armen
pour lui donner un cours d'histoire.
Il a une petite
idée derrière la tête.
Son rêve, c'est de construire
un grand hôtel sur son terrain.
Regardez.
Il voudrait bien convaincre
Armen d'investir de l'argent
dans un projet
d'agrandissement de sa maison.
Je te le dis, plein d'artistes et
célébrités qui viennent sur cette plage.
Je les connais tous.
Ils veulent un endroit un peu tranquille,
privé pour passer des vacances.
Tu comprends ?
Dans un hôtel quelconque,
tout le monde se jette sur toi,
tu dois signer des autographes.
Oui je comprends.
Si je pouvais les loger ici,
il n'y aurait aucun problème
car c'est protégé ici.
Il ne viendrait qu'une
ou deux fois par an.
Mais non, mais
non, pas du tout.
Je connais tellement
de gens du showbiz.
Quand je leur parle du projet,
ils trouvent tous ça génial.
Il y aurait du monde
en permanence, je te l'assure.
Bon, fait-moi confiance.
Allez, on en reparle
plus tard, je dois y aller.
Pas sûr, qu'Armen, sois convaincu.
Et de toute façon,
il ne décide pas seul.
À l'autre bout de la ville,
voilà le QG des deux frères.
Surveillé par une dizaine de caméras,
c'est la maison familiale.
Tous les dimanches, c'est là
que se retrouve le clan Babokokian.
Dans la propriété
des sculptures géantes de lions
et des gargouilles inspirées
de Notre-Dame de Paris montent la garde.
L'intérieur ressemble
à un château fort, ambiance médiévale.
Un peu partout dans la maison,
les initiales de leur entreprise,
GDG pour George Dental Group.
Et ce lion, l'armoirie
que la famille s'est inventée.
Maman c'est sympa,
viens nous dire bonjour.
Celle qui accueille, c'est
la matriarche, la mère des deux frères.
Elle est russe, à ses côtés,
la femme d'Edouard Olga
et Karina l'épouse d'Armen.
Il y a aussi quelques amis
en tout, trois générations
autour de la table.
La petite dernière a sept mois.
Elle est où maman ?
Allez, on va porter un toast à l'amitié.
À l'amitié et surtout aux rencontres.
Dans le clan Babokokian,
on trinque
avec des vins français
et on déguste
des produits venus d'Europe.
La Russie est pourtant soumise
à un embargo économique
occidental depuis 2014
à cause de l'annexion de la Crimée.
Regardez ça, c'est un fromage
italien, on me l'a ramené de Hong Kong.
Mais Armen s'en moque.
C'est de la contrebande,
un citoyen russe n'a pas
le droit de posséder ce produit.
C'est de la nourriture hors la loi.
C'est un ami chinois
qui me ramène ça.
Il m'a rapporté
deux kilos de parmesan.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autre ?
Du vin italien, du vin australien
et aussi du vin français.
On peut tout avoir
sans problème ici.
Les deux frères et leurs amis
sont très attachés à leurs
racines européennes.
Le thème revient
régulièrement sur la table.
Regardez moi,
je suis un Européen.
J'aime beaucoup
la langue en français.
Pourtant, c'est l'Asie ici.
Non mais non, non.
Si nous sommes en Asie, voyons.
Mais si on est en Asie.
Oui, nous sommes en Asie, mais moi,
je considère être un homme européen.
J'ai la mentalité d'un Européen.
Mais non, ici,
c'est 100 % l'Asie.
Mais évidemment,
géographiquement, c'est l'Asie.
Mentalement, nous sommes
Européens, nous vivons comme eux.
Nous sommes Européens,
mais des Européens avec un côté asiatique,
parce qu'on a une sensibilité asiatique.
Donc, on est vraiment
un mélange des deux cultures.
Ce qui est sûr, c'est que côté tourisme,
Vladivostok joue la carte de l'Asie.
Chaque année, elle accueille près
de 200 mille Japonais, Coréens et Chinois.
Un chiffre en constante augmentation.
Ils viennent chercher ici
un parfum d'Europe et de bord de mer.
Pour attirer les capitaux
et les touristes chinois,
le gouvernement
a créé au nord de la ville
une zone spéciale où les entreprises
payent moins d'impôts.
Le symbole de cette
zone franche, c'est ce casino.
Le Tigre de cristal
en français dans le texte.
Il a été construit presque uniquement
pour capter les joueurs chinois.
Il n'y a en effet aucun casino en Chine,
un pays pourtant obsédé par le jeu.
Au Tigre de Cristal,
on joue 24 heures sur 24.
Des vols arrivent
de Chine toutes les heures.
Le responsable de l'hôtel du casino,
Théo Terzopoullos, est franco-grec.
Il dirige près de 1000 employés.
On a aussi le groupe
de 140 personnes qui arrive.
Pour les Chinois de Pékin, il est
plus rapide de se rendre à Vladivostok
que d'aller jouer dans
l'autre empire du jeu asiatique, Macao.
On est très proche des pays asiatiques,
de nos clients de l'hôtel,
on a 85% qui viennent de l'Asie
et plus de la Chine du Nord.
Pour attirer les riches Chinois,
Théo a un atout dans sa manche,
cette suite présidentielle.
180 mètres carrés avec un sauna
pour la touche de tradition russe
et une salle de bain
de 50 mètres carrés.
C'est la chambre la plus
grande de l'hôtel,
mais la chambre
la plus grande à Vladivostok aussi.
Avec ça, c'est aussi
la chambre la plus chère.
C'est à peu près 1 500 € par nuit.
Pour chouchouter ses clients,
le casino a aussi recruté un Russe
d'origine coréenne qui parle le chinois.
Je vous présente Kirill,
en fait, c'est le responsable
pour les relations
avec nos clients VIP chinois.
Il nous emmène dans une salle
de jeux conçue spécialement
pour les joueurs chinois.
Nous attendons des clients
chinois incessamment sous peu
donc on ne va pas
pouvoir rester très longtemps.
Les chinois ne jouent
qu'à un seul jeu le Baccara,
car c'est un jeu
uniquement basé sur la chance.
Cette table de jeu a été spécialement
conçue pour nos clients chinois.
Comme vous pouvez le voir,
il n'y a pas de chiffre quatre,
car, pour les Chinois,
le quatre représente la mort.
Même souci du détail pour
le plus grand restaurant du casino.
La carte est chinoise,
le chef est chinois
et on y mange le plat
préféré des Chinois le crabe.
Jusqu'au nom du restaurant qui n'a
pas été choisi par hasard, le Double huit.
Encore une fois,
c'est une histoire de superstition.
Le restaurant s'appelle
le Double huit car pour les chinois,
ce chiffre symbolise la richesse.
Aujourd'hui, c'est soirée
spéciale au Tigre de Cristal.
Stellios Ciphedakis,
le big boss, un Grec lui aussi,
fait une dernière
tournée d'inspection.
Comment ça va ?
Vous êtes prêts ?
Tout est OK pour ce soir ?
À quelle heure
on va avoir les DJ déjà, 8 h ?
L'ambition de Stellios,
c'est de faire parler de son établissement
dans toute l'Asie
et il a mis le paquet.
C'est un peu la folie ici.
Tous nos artistes sont en train
de se préparer pour la fête de ce soir.
Nous fêtons
nos deux ans d'existence.
Nous organisons une énorme fête
pour remercier à la fois
nos employés et nos fidèles clients.
On a pu constater depuis deux ans
que le casino a énormément développé
le tourisme dans toute
la région de Vladivostok.
Bonsoir messieurs, ça va ?
Tout va bien ?
Les propriétaires du casino
ont fait le déplacement pour l'occasion.
Ce sont aussi des chinois.
Ils viennent de Hong Kong
et souhaitent rester discrets.
L'attraction de la soirée,
c'est la venue de Moscou
de la plus grande star de la pop russe
Yucha.
Ces clips cumulent plus
de 300 millions de vues sur YouTube.
Tout va bien ?
Tu peux leur dire
de filmer mon bon profil ?
J'adore mon pays.
Et quand j'arrive ici à Vladivostok,
je mesure
l'immensité de la Russie.
C'est vraiment un long chemin
pour venir jusqu'ici depuis Moscou.
J'ai vite senti à quel point l'ambiance
était différente dans cette ville.
Les gens ici sont différents
mais surtout très chaleureux.
2500 spectateurs
se pressent dans l'établissement.
Il est temps pour la pop star venue
de Moscou de faire son entrée en scène.
C'est extraordinaire,
regardez autour de vous.
C'est un immense succès.
Les gens continuent
d'arriver en nombre.
Je ne pouvais pas
rêver mieux pour cet anniversaire.
Derrière le clinquant
du nouveau Vladivostok,
la cité soviétique
n'a pas disparu, loin de là.
La plus grande partie de la ville,
ce sont des barres HLM,
des maisonnettes en tôle ondulée
et des terrains vagues.
L'hiver, les températures peuvent
descendre jusqu'à -25 degrés.
Pas facile d'y survivre
pour les exclus du rêve de Vladivostok.
Nous sommes dimanche
dans un quartier populaire de la ville.
Une association
distribue des repas chauds
et des produits de première nécessité.
Il y a du monde.
Vous avez encore des pommes ?
Il m'en reste.
En plus, c'est plein de vitamines.
Ils sont une demi-douzaine
de bénévoles.
La plupart ont moins de 30 ans.
Ils viennent ici chaque semaine.
Tenez, prenez ça.
Il y a du thé
et un peu de pain.
Parmi eux, Sofia, elle est institutrice,
elle a 21 ans.
Beaucoup de gens viennent nous voir.
On n'aide pas seulement les SDF.
Aujourd'hui, il y a
de plus en plus de pauvres
et de vieilles personnes
qui sont dans le besoin.
À Vladivostok,
malheur aux laissés pour compte !
Cette femme de 45 ans habite
dans un immeuble tout proche.
Elle vient chaque dimanche.
Je suis une mère célibataire,
je vis avec très peu de moyens.
Mon jeune fils a une maladie génétique,
il fait des crises d'épilepsie.
Ici, on nous aide beaucoup,
je ne pourrai jamais les remercier assez.
En plein hiver à Vladivostok,
il y a même des gens
qui par ces températures
glaciales, vivent dans la rue.
C'est le cas de Nicolaï.
Il vient de récupérer des provisions
sur le parvis de l'église orthodoxe.
Nous l'accompagnons.
Il a établi ses quartiers d'hiver,
à deux pas d'une zone HLM.
Il s'est installé au milieu
de ces énormes tuyaux d'eau chaude
alimentent la ville
en chauffage central.
Il s'est constitué
un minuscule chez soi
sous une simple planche.
Quand il fait vraiment trop froid,
j'allume un petit feu,
j'ai une grosse couverture
et si je me colle contre les tuyaux,
j'arrive à me réchauffer.
Cela fait un an et demi
que Nikolaï s'est installé ici.
Il a 65 ans.
Il est originaire de Kaliningrad,
complètement à l'autre bout de la Russie.
Depuis qu'il a perdu ses papiers,
il ne peut plus toucher sa retraite,
ni se déplacer en Russie.
J'ai toujours beaucoup voyagé.
Aujourd'hui, mon rêve, c'est d'aller
finir ma vie près de l'océan Arctique.
J'ai rêvé
que je mourrais là-bas,
et mes rêves
m'ont toujours guidé.
Oh là là, mes mains sont vraiment sales.
Je vais essayer
de me laver bientôt.
À Vladivostok,
il n'y a pas un seul
hébergement de nuit
pour les SDF comme lui.
Cette capitale du bout du monde
est pourtant une des villes
les plus surveillées du pays.
Été comme hiver, toute la ville
est quadrillée par la police.
Le président Poutine veut
en faire une vitrine de la Russie.
Bonjour Monsieur,
veuillez me présenter vos papiers,
assurance et permis de conduire.
Les policiers ont
beaucoup à faire à des hommes ivres
ou à des petits voleurs.
Il est où là, le gars ?
Comme ce soir,
un voleur de voiture.
L'homme risque jusqu'à
cinq ans de prison ferme.
Est-ce la police ou est-ce le froid ?
La ville en hiver
est une des plus sûres de Russie.
Vladivostok est à la même
latitude que la Côte d'Azur.
Et pourtant, l'hiver dure six mois,
d'octobre à mars.
La mer gèle et la couche de
glace atteint un mètre d'épaisseur.
La tradition ici, c'est
d'en profiter pour aller pêcher.
Alors ça mord aujourd'hui ?
La technique est originale.
Vous savez, pêcher ici,
ça présente des risques.
Les périodes les plus
dangereuses sont novembre et mars,
quand la glace est fine.
Mais en plein hiver,
aucun problème.
Bon, c'est vrai,
il y a des morts chaque année.
Mais nous, les pêcheurs,
on a le goût du danger.
Sur des kilomètres, des centaines
de voitures de pêcheurs,
parfois très loin de la côte.
Chacun se confronte
à la nature sauvage
et fait ses petits
trous de son côté
pour un résultat
souvent bien maigre.
Certains jeunes de la ville
cherchent d'autres sensations fortes.
Eux non plus,
l'hiver ne leur fait pas peur.
À une demi-heure du centre ville, nous
rencontrons Dalil et Youri 25 et 31 ans.
Ce jour-là, il fait -25.
Leur plaisir à eux, quelle
que soit la saison, c'est le surf.
Ils profitent de cette baie
qui n'est jamais prise par les glaces.
Évidemment, on préfère surfer l'été
en short avec des jeunes
filles qui nous regardent.
C'est vrai que les gens
sont curieux de nous voir.
Ils sont surpris de voir des gens
plonger comme ça dans l'eau glaciale.
Notre courage, en inspire certains
et d'autres nous prennent
pour des gros idiots.
Mais pour les riches, le chic,
c'est d'aller pêcher dans le Grand Nord.
Nous retrouvons Edouard,
un des frères millionnaires.
Chaque mois, il emmène avec
lui des amis dans sa résidence secondaire
dans la forêt sibérienne.
La route est bonne.
On a un temps magnifique,
tout est parfait.
Je sens qu'on va bien se marrer.
Après quelques heures de voiture,
nous atteignons
une base d'hélicoptère.
Le reste du trajet doit
s'effectuer par les airs.
Les deux frères possèdent
leur propre appareil.
Un EMI2, qui date de l'époque soviétique.
Nous survolons la Taïga,
cette forêt de bouleaux et de sapins
qui recouvre la quasi
totalité du territoire russe.
Il faut près d'une heure et demie
pour arriver à destination.
Perdu au milieu de la forêt,
nous sommes à plus de
100 kilomètres de toute civilisation.
Cette résidence secondaire est un complexe
de plus d'une dizaine de bâtiments.
Chaque invité a droit
à son chalet particulier.
On peut y vivre en totale autarcie,
et dans le plus grand confort.
Armen, le grand frère,
est arrivé plus tôt dans la journée.
Les deux Arméniens
ont racheté la propriété
à la veuve
d'un autre millionnaire,
mort dans un accident
d'hélicoptère pendant une tempête
à quelques minutes de là.
Sa veuve en voulait
deux ou trois millions de dollars.
Au final, on lui a fait
une offre et elle n'a pas pu refuser.
Pour vivre ici, premièrement,
il faut être très riche
et deuxièmement, il faut
aimer vivre en pleine nature.
Je ne connais pas
beaucoup de milliardaires qui ont envie
de vivre sous -40 degrés.
Il faut être un peu taré comme nous.
Accrochées au mur tous les trophées
de chasse des deux frères,
des loups, des bouquetins,
des sangliers, ou encore un élan.
Il y a trois ans, un ami à moi
a tué cet animal âgé d'environ douze ans.
C'est vraiment
une bête impressionnante.
C'est très rare et je n'avais
jamais vu des bois aussi beaux.
Côté équipement,
il y a tout ce qu'il faut.
Des motoneiges et des hélicoptères,
les frères en possèdent trois
au total pour plus de sécurité.
Ce matin, ils ont décidé
d'aller à la pêche à la truite.
Direction une rivière gelée
à plusieurs kilomètres de là.
La Taïga regorge d'animaux sauvages.
Ici, une harde de sangliers.
Là, des élans.
Après 20 minutes de vol,
c'est le moment de mettre en place
le camp de pêche.
Arrête d'insister, tu vois
bien que tu n'y arrives pas.
Arrête d'y toucher,
je vais te montrer.
Tu vois,
je suis sûr que tu l'as abîmé.
Armen connaît le coin par cœur.
Sous cette glace, la rivière
est très poissonneuse.
Tu fais un trou ici et un autre là,
et puis un troisième plus loin, là-bas.
Comble du luxe, il a amené
des grenouilles vivantes
qu'il a fait venir de Chine.
Et de toutes petites cannes à pêche.
Sous la glace,
c'est le calme plat,
et puis soudain.
Il est beau celui-là,
il doit avoir au moins deux ans.
On les laisse dans la neige
et en 30 minutes, ils meurent congelés.
Parfois ici, ça ne mord pas du tout car,
les poissons sont partis dormir ou autre.
Parfois en 2 h, ça n'arrête pas, on prend
du poisson toutes les cinq minutes.
Ça, c'est un linok.
Cinq cigares, quinze trous
et 40 grenouilles plus tard,
il est temps de préparer le barbecue.
Pour le bois,
il suffit de se servir sur place.
Ce qu'ils adorent, c'est la vie
sauvage et la bonne chère.
C'est la tradition quand on vient
pêcher, on prépare la soupe de poisson.
Elle est congelée,
mais on va la réchauffer.
On rajoute du poisson, des épices,
du sel, du poivre et le tour est joué.
Le poisson pêché
il y a quelques minutes,
est préparé sur place
par l'homme à tout faire.
Il est arménien comme
tous les employés du campement.
Entre nous,
on l'appelle Paul Bocuse.
C'est le Paul Bocuse d'Arménie.
En réalité, le résultat est
assez loin de la grande cuisine.
Il ne s'agit pas d'attraper des poissons,
on peut en acheter au magasin.
Le but, c'est de passer du bon temps ici.
Passer du temps dans la nature,
sans téléphone portable.
Pas de prise de tête, pas de discussion
sur la politique, pas de business.
C'est relaxant,
tu apaises ton esprit.
Quand je rentre, je me sens beaucoup
mieux et j'ai des nouvelles idées.
Ici, on se nettoie l'esprit.
Si les deux frères viennent ici tous
les mois, c'est surtout pour faire la fête
sans femme, entre potes,
et c'est forcément toujours très arrosé.
Super, de la vodka !
C'est de la vodka à 70 degrés.
Le breuvage dans une bouteille
en plastique est fait maison en Arménie.
On va trinquer pour
Poutine et Macron.
Pour Poutine ok,
mais pas pour Macron.
Macron, il aime les vieilles alors que,
Poutine aime les femmes plus jeunes.
c'est pour ça
qu'on vote pour Poutine.
On plaisante, on aime
bien Macron et Poutine.
Ce sont
tous deux des bons présidents.
On les aime bien.
Les toasts s'enchaînent
jusque tard dans la soirée.
Allez, à la Russie les amis !
La nuit se terminera au bania,
une tradition russe.
Armen, tu es prêt, on y va.
Une sorte de sauna.
Moi, j'essaie d'en
faire deux fois par semaine,
surtout quand tu vas
chasser ou pêcher, c'est indispensable.
Bon, je reconnais que ça aide
aussi à évacuer l'alcool.
On se fouette mutuellement
avec des branches de bouleau
avant de se jeter dans la neige.
Même par -30 degrés,
impossible pour eux de renoncer
aux plaisirs
de ce bout du monde.